book TV is bringing you selected panels
from the 2009 Brooklyn Book Festival
panel 3 is a discussion on the current
economic climate with Time magazine
Business and Economics columnist Justin
Fox weekly columnist for the nation and
the Guardian Naomi Klein and the Village
Voice the progressive and Mother Jones
writer Kai right oh good afternoon thank
you all for coming I think there may be
a few seats in the front but uh I can't
don't hold me to that but I hope
everybody can get comfortable we're
gonna have a great discussion I'd like
to welcome you all I'm Errol Lewis I'm a
columnist at the New York Daily News I
host a morning show on wwr L radio here
in New York and some fans here that
includes a book club that has a number
of different volumes that we go through
pretty regularly let me introduce our
panelists and then we're gonna have a
discussion about the economy the state
of the economy who's to blame and what
we can expect as we try and get through
these difficult times
Justin Fox is an economist and Business
Economics and business columnist for
Time magazine prior to that he spent
over a decade at Fortune magazine
including a stint as the magazine's
Europe editor based in London his first
book the myth of the rational market is
first sale around here I hear CAI right
is a Brooklyn based writer he's a senior
writer for the route calm and for a host
of other pop publications he's the
author of drifting toward love black
brown gay and coming of age on the
streets of New York and Naomi Klein is
an award-winning columnist and author of
the number one best-selling the Shock
Doctrine the rise of disaster capitalism
which is being translated into 27
languages I hear so congratulations on
that um folks I want to we want to keep
this a kind of a conversation and then
we'll invite you all to join us in the
last 20 or so minutes
I'm curious and I'd like to hear from
each of the panelists how did we get
here what do you think of where we are
right now there's a lot of talk about
this being the worst recession since the
1930s other draw can others draw can
to two other periods why in your opinion
are we where we are who's to blame if
there's blame to be assigned is was this
inevitable was this cyclical did you see
it coming why don't we start with you
Justin funky Mike first of all this is
the worst recession since the Great
Depression at least in the u.s. because
I am sort of a data geek and I like to
look at all these releases when they
come out from the Bureau of Labor
Statistics and the like and it's just it
this is now surpassed the seventies
recession in the early 80s recession in
terms of what I mean clearly this is a
recession brought on by a financial
meltdown and I mean recessions happen
there are business cycles and that's not
ever going to be banished but this
particular severity of this one clearly
had something to do with the rampant
growth of the financial sector and it's
sort of I don't know going off on this
tangent of its own that didn't have a
whole lot to do with facilitating real
economic activity and that all collapsed
and that's happened before in different
countries it's happened before in the
u.s. we're dealing with it differently
this time but and and presumably
somewhat better than in the 30s but it's
still pretty bad
few communities that were targeted
pretty hard in both subprime lending and
not just the subprime stuff but the but
the all day and then and the the whole
host of junk mortgages and what is
striking about it is the way we've we've
talked about this as though it's you
know it's just a cultural problem and
that everybody is culpable in some way
everybody from Wall Street to homeowners
they're all culpable in some way in this
and it's just not true it doesn't hold
up when you start looking at either the
data or at real lives of neighborhoods
where these loans were made you see
folks who a had been homeowners for a
long time had been responsible borrowers
for a long time and then we're targeted
to become irresponsible borrowers and
from from the loan officers to the
underwriters to lobbyists who are you
part of did we predict this I mean
several states predicted it I'm in
trying to pass laws to prevent it and
we're and faced aggressive lobbying to
get those laws repealed so so I think a
big part of this is predation and I
think that's an important thing to keep
in mind as we talk about what are the
solutions
if this mic on my own now
is it on now it is on now okay yeah I'm
gonna try not to repeat with what what
Justin and KY just said because you know
I largely agree with it and and I think
Kai's point is particularly important
that that this language of shared
responsibility is particularly insidious
because it you know if it is everybody's
problem then it's nobody's problem and
there has been really total impunity for
the people who are responsible I mean
besides Madoff there haven't been any
prosecutions and there haven't been any
correction so the New York Times has
been reporting over the past couple of
days that the financial sector has not
been reregulate it and so we have lost
and this is what's particularly
important for us to understand at this
one-year mark because we are at exactly
one year from the collapse of Lehman the
collapse of AIG this week was the horror
week a year ago and what we know from
our own financial lives and what we know
from the actions of huge institutions
like the International Monetary Fund is
when people really need bailing out or
country's really need bailing out that's
a moment of extraordinary leverage on
the part of the people who are doing the
bailing out you can ask pretty much
anything under the Sun when you're
handing out billions of dollars let
alone trillions of dollars and what we
see it one year later after this
bipartisan bailout of the wealthiest
sector of our society and the
abandonment of the most vulnerable
sectors of society in terms of
homeowners and and people who've lost
jobs is that that leverage was totally
squandered the the trillions were handed
out and nothing was asked in return not
just in terms of what are you going to
do with the money but how will you
change your behavior to prevent a crisis
like this from happening so yeah when
you throw trillions of dollars at
anything you will get a temporary fix
but as far as I'm concerned we're still
very much in the crisis the crisis is
not over and the other thing that I
think this is really revealed is an
incredible double standard and when we
cry crisis
because of course many communities were
in crisis before a year ago last year
and continue to be in crisis but all of
the urgency is being lost because Wall
Street is feeling so much better and the
good times are rolling again the
president in fact will be speaking on
Wall Street tomorrow impart in
commemoration I guess of the meltdown a
year ago but let's let's let's try this
I'd like each of you to give us your
short list of what the media in
particular should be covering I mean
what is being overlooked if if this
language of shared responsibility is
inappropriate what might be some ways to
maybe draw out some of the sort of
sharpen the story and make sure that
we're informing people about who is to
blame well I always like to blame Larry
Summers but all that yeah I guess my
thought was I want someone who's not in
the middle of the middle of the
mainstream media like me to start
answering that question but I mean I
think you're absolutely right guy that
this it's some level I go crazy with all
of the the goldman sachs conspiracy
theories but on the other hand just sort
of oh we all fail together is a really
lame response to it and I think in
general especially in terms of like the
business media electronic business media
and then to accept certain extent the
print media although with all these
commemorations the last few days it's
the question has been raised more often
that there really hasn't been an attempt
to say okay this is your fault
let's or maybe this isn't this person's
fault but this is this practices fault
how do we make sure this doesn't happen
anymore
and I don't mean it's the kind of thing
I'm sure there are people out there
writing this I'm sure it's being focused
on someone but you you passed that
moment of crisis I mean I wonder now
he's the problem that Hank Paulson did
not believe in the Shock Doctrine and
failed to use it against the bank
I think the Paulson believed in the
Shock Doctrine and
it had a 700 billion dollar price tag
but this is you know for those of you
who aren't familiar with the thesis of
my book it's that extreme right-wing
ideology but but in particular what I
call corporatism not free-market
ideology but but these massive transfers
Wells from from from the public to the
private take place historically in
moments of extreme crisis when we are
panicked and when we tend to want to
believe that there's a group of
all-knowing experts out there who
understand that's very very complex
stuff much better than we do so we
should just sit back and and and trust
them I think the confusing thing about
this crisis is that it was so obvious
that it was created by extreme
right-wing market ideology that
everybody was claiming to be renouncing
it at the same time as you had this
absolutely unprecedented heist of public
money and a transferred into private
hands so I think people thought that
action was being taken and correctives
were being put into place and so yeah
the Cato Institute and others issued
papers going Minoso shelach doctrine but
this isn't socialism in any way shape or
form its intervention in the market on
behalf of the elites and as it happens
you needed to throw out the free market
ideology in order to rationalize this
intervention because you couldn't have
done it otherwise but in the same way
that during good times free market
ideology rationalizes less affair in the
interests of the elites during a crisis
it has rationalized this is
unprecedented transfer of wealth but I
think this crisis has absolutely been
exploited in the way that I described in
the book and and Hank Paulson was really
I mean just so blatant about it well if
we remember that that wonderful three
page memo where it was just kind of like
a ransom note to the country right and
give me seven hundred billion dollars
and this can't be reviewed by any branch
of government or any court of law right
I mean there's no there isn't much more
of a blatant example
this exploitation of crisis in order to
get both money and power than that
particular three-page memo which
thankfully was amended because of public
uproar right if only I've always
wondered why Paul's because he knew
Congress had to know Congress would
react that way I guess the one thing I'd
throw out there is I'd still rather that
they did that last fall than that they
didn't because I have this feeling that
there might have been this complete
falling apart of the financial system
that could have led to shock doctrines
from either side and but but I totally
agree that because of the seeming
temporary success of the bailout now
suddenly the sort of political force to
do something about the wall street
practices that brought us brought us
here in the first place is gone so I'm
kind of stuck in the middle there
because I really did not want to
experience what would have happened this
was the only alternative right I mean I
don't think anybody was advocating doing
nothing the question was what what Cato
Institute was they'll they waited a
while before they started advocating to
him after after they had already
allocated the money but the issue is who
are you going to bail out and and this
is you know I think what's heartbreaking
about it when we remember that this was
what Obama was saying one year ago was
that we can't just bail out Wall Street
we can't have a top-down bailout we have
to have a bottom-up bailout and there
were all kinds of ideas that were being
advocated by people like Sheila Bair
about the need to bail out homeowners
that could have had the same stabilizing
effect without the what we've seen which
is this deepening of inequality which in
many ways is at the root of this is the
source of the crisis so I think we need
to reject the idea that that the choice
was between doing something and doing
nothing and because the something sort
of worked that justifies it because that
was never the choice I think we also
need to reject the idea that this is
something that we did in the past
right I mean one of the getting back to
the question about how we're covering it
one of the frustrating things is this
assumption that it's over
and that that there's no that we've
we've done a fix we spent all the money
last year and now it's over and the
reality is that we are seeing 360,000
foreclosures a month and it went up
seven percent this month which is a in a
thirty two percent over the last year
and it's gonna keep going up and so we
are still bleeding and we are
particularly bleeding in the inin
communities that were targeted for this
predation in urban communities and black
and Latino families we are bleeding
still and there's angry to this day do
not have a plan on the table to deal
with that there is we gave we have the
the smaller version of the bailout is
the seventy five billion dollars that
the about administration decided to give
to mortgage servicers to try to convince
them to stop foreclosing to give them
incentives to work with borrowers as
opposed to rushing to foreclosure it has
not worked it simply hasn't worked the
Treasury data they they they the numbers
sound great on their face you know that
oh we've got 85% of servicers are
involved in the program and they've
offered some hundreds of thousands of
offers have gone out but one month were
closures overwhelms the progress made in
the entirety of the program today
and even if it achieves its goal of
helping three million borrowers that'll
barely cover the foreclosures this year
and so the bottom line is that we have
from President Bush's on through
President Obama we have decided that
we're going to deal with this
voluntarily we're going to take we're
gonna tell banks and servicers and the
entire home loan industry we're gonna
give you incentives to fix this and it
has not worked we are going to have to
have a more heavy-handedness and and and
and the and the bailout was was we can
debate it but that was then and I think
that we really in terms of the coverage
now need to be talking about what has to
happen today what do we still have to do
to stop all these foreclosures have you
or anybody else seen a
program that looks hopeful that would go
more to the root of the problem and
address the actual homeowners as opposed
to the many people in the chain that
don't seem to want to help there's a lot
of ideas out there and we can you know
and there and there's been a lot of back
and forth debate and I think that the
central concept is that something has to
be done to give borrowers more leverage
that the only people who can have any
chance and when when they start getting
in trouble are people who go get a
lawyer and most people don't have a
lawyer and and so there has to be
something from the top that gives the
borrower greater leverage in
negotiations with the banks and again
this is why the original point is
important that this started with
predation these are people who got into
this situation through predation and and
also regardless of what even if we don't
believe in that these are the
communities are being rotted out because
of these foreclosures and so we have to
give borrowers and I'm heavier hand in
negotiation with the banks one theory of
that was - was bankruptcy reform was to
allow that was to allow it so currently
you can modify your life.you if you have
a loan for a boat or a are you know a
second home or you can go to you can get
in bankruptcy the judge can modify the
mortgage you cannot do that on primary
residence that's a that's a carve out
for industry that they've written in
there was a proposal to get rid of that
carve out Senate Democrats voted it down
there it's so and and the result is that
we don't have any we still have
foreclosures coming a pace there there
has to be something to give borrowers
more leverage and so we need to come up
with an idea of what that's going to be
it's not going to be bankruptcy reform
which it should be
we need something well not just one one
one point that I think you know when we
look at at the failure to to regulate
the the financial sector the failure to
deal with the for closure closure crisis
and now the crisis in in health care
reform it seems to me that the issue the
meta issue the issue before any other
issue
it's political and campaign finance
reform I mean this it's almost like you
know we can we can talk about all kinds
of wonderful ideas that we have and just
knowing full well that none of it will
happen just as we've seen all of these
fantastic ideas either defeated or taken
off the table before they were even on
the table because of the outrageous
power of the lobbyists in Washington and
I think this needs to be the mass
movement of our time because no other
movement matters unless we deal with the
corruption of money in politics we we're
anticipating a Supreme Court decision on
that very topic which may or may not
help address some of those those those
issues but what do people think of the
2010 elections I mean in theory since
everyone in the lower house of Congress
and a third of the Senate have to go
back to the people and get themselves
reelected next year this would be a
chance for millions of foreclosed home
owners and for others to make their
their voices heard make wishes known do
you foresee any hope toward
re-regulation or a change in the
conversation I mean everything I've seen
so well and you just can't tell at this
point because what what the polls are
saying it'll depend a lot on the economy
next year everything else but it it
seems like most of the political
movement is in the opposite direction of
that right now which yeah it doesn't
bode well for your reregulate actually I
mean I think one of the one of the
things that I found most striking about
2009 and this is something that I've
heard Naomi say before is how how
passive the progressive community has
become and you know when I think about
the healthcare town hall forums and I
think of all of this anger around health
care nobody has more reason to be
disrupting forums and shouting down
presidents than black people around
health care you know I mean we've got
you name the you name the
the indicator and african-americans are
are far more likely to both get it and
die from it
and and and and yet we hear nothing from
from from the black community about it I
think that a lot of folks whatever their
political party who invested greatly in
2008 felt like their job was done and
that at the end of that is sit back and
about we we bought our president you
know we sort of deal with politics as
consumption you know we bought our
president and now he'll go off and deal
with it and and we'll sit back and wait
and I had I think that that's a recipe
for disaster
you know I assume that we're all
Keynesian here or at least we're
familiar with the idea that what's most
missing right now in the economy and the
need for the stimulus is based on this
decline in spending so with spending
down and savings up by individual
households that seems to be what the
data suggest have we are we going in the
wrong direction is our people doing what
might be in their best individual
interest but actually sort of slowing
down the economy at the same time and
how long is this likely to last I mean I
think people should do what's in their
own individual interest and that's why
we have governments to make collective
decisions it aren't necessarily that
didn't matter on the government side and
that's that I think that was always
Keynes his argument as well so if if you
have this long period of everybody
rebuilding their savings then it really
would make a lot of sense to have
government investing in things that
haven't been invested in for the last 25
or 30 years and and at the same time I
mean clearly over I am NOT a good
remembering data at moments like this
guy but consumer spending as a portion
of the overall economy in the u.s. was
it used to be in the low 60s maybe even
high 50s in the post-world War two ERA
and then it just started this steady
rise in the early
and it's been above 70% of the economy
the last couple years and I mean there's
no law that says that can't be but it
doesn't seem to have worked out very
well so it would probably be better if
we replace that that 80% with more
government spending I mean government
spending and business investment are the
two things that can they can take that
take that spot but I mean I always worry
a little bit when we look at it from the
consumption end because so much of there
is an overconsumption problem in this
country and people do try to shop their
way out of crises and that's not
necessarily good either for the planet
or for individual households because
they end up carrying more debt so I
think I mean really what we've lost is
the Keynesian idea that you could deal
with it from the jobs perspective as
opposed to from the consumption
perspective and that to me has been the
most striking missing piece I mean at
least there's a discussion about what
maybe we should be doing to stop
foreclosures but we really aren't
talking at all about what we should be
doing to stop layoffs and and keep and
protect good jobs in this country
there's no talk of it and and really
what this crisis has ended up it's
starting to look like is is just the
final decimation of the manufacturing
sector in this country that's one of the
lasting effects of this crisis and I
always think in terms of lost
opportunities but also an example of
what a really progressive stimulus
program would look like I always think
about that remarkable factory Republic
windows and doors that where the the
Chicago Factory 250 workers were laid
off right before Christmas three days
notice they were making windows and
doors and they refused to be laid off
they decided that this was wrong and
they occupied their their Factory and
protected the machines with their bodies
they slept there because what happens
when a factory is closed is that the
machines are auctioned off the parts are
auctioned off in order to pay the
creditors they said we're creditors
because this company owes us money but
more than that they also followed the
money and
realize that the reason why they were
being fired was because Bank of America
had not given a loan to to their factory
owner and of course by this point
Bank of America had received twenty five
billion dollars in bailout funds in the
name of more lending so these very smart
workers and they're and they're very
smart small Union Widow and I say it's
small because I think part of this has
to do with the actual real democracy
within this workplace that often is
missing when you have very large unions
who aren't who are less interested in
workplace democracy they decided that
they were going to make the issue Bank
of America and the bailout and if we all
remember this but I think it you know
it's worth remembering again those
fantastic signs you got bailed out we
got sold out but what was so striking
about this was this was a company that
clearly could have been part of the new
greenie pump economy right and and they
kept it open and now they have a buyer
who's come in he's getting some stimulus
money because there's part of the
stimulus money is is going to
retrofitting homes and businesses using
more energy-efficient windows and doors
so there was no reason no logical reason
why this factory should have been
allowed to close and it was because of
direct action that it stayed open
they found a buyer but if you look at
this as an example it actually is this
little window into what a progressive
bailout would be so to me what this says
is why don't we have a bailout that
before any factory is allowed to close
there has to be there have to be two
questions asked one some sort of a green
audit done that asks could this factory
in some way be retrofitted to be part of
this new green economy we keep hearing
about and what sort of investment could
be made what sort of targeted investment
technological investment could be made
to change a factory to change an
autoparts factory into a factory that
could be making subway cars for instance
right and also do the whiff though if
the owners don't think that's profitable
enough do the workers want to turn it
into a cooperative and that would be a
situation where you need legislative
reforms so the workers become the first
as opposed to the last creditors right
so imagine if this was happening across
the board that's a bottom-up bailout
that's protecting jobs and it means that
when people shop they're actually
shopping with money they have as opposed
to money they don't have and debt
they're accumulating and you know we're
not hearing any about any of these ideas
but they're out there when we talk about
reregulate there's been a remarkable set
of revelations around the Bernie Madoff
Ponzi scheme about what he got away with
right literally under the noses of the
SEC and how state regulation was used to
aid and abet this a number of different
schemes not only by him but by many of
the insurance companies what do you
think of the prospects for for
reregulate inand what's the role that
the states need to play in that whole
process hey I guess I think the
prospects for better regulation of
scammers like Bernie Madoff are pretty
good now just cuz there's there's actual
people at the SEC are happy to be
working there again they're not they're
part of an administration that doesn't
totally denigrate you need people to do
that so that kind of regulation I think
that's gonna work better there's gonna
be lots more the IRS is gonna be tougher
on people the SEC is gonna be tougher on
people the bigger questions of what how
our financial system is supposed to look
and and what different institutions are
allowed to do how big they're allowed to
get none of that's really been dealt
with at all and and I mean and that is
the kind of thing with every passing
month it seems less likely that it could
stolen you know sometimes it seems like
New York and our Attorney General in
particular both the current and the
former attorney general seem like the
the main state actors who want to step
into the middle of this national
conversation
well sometimes just the main actors
period having made government actors of
any kind I mean definitely what Spitzer
back then there was nobody else yeah I
mean is are we just lucky or is it a
perception issue but I mean they're the
49 other attorneys general and a whole
bunch of bank and insurance regulators
all over the place do none of them want
a piece of this thing well the
Massachusetts Attorney General is big on
this too but I guess it just it works
better if you
or in the media center and and then also
in the scam center - yeah I don't know I
mean I that is a very weird phenomenon
of the past decade that New York state
attorneys general have been sort of the
lead regulators of the financial system
I don't think that's probably the best
way to do it well but I mean it returns
to your previous play with 40% of New
York's economy became Wall Street and
that's just an unsustainable economy by
anybody's measure and so I there was
more reason to do it here right they
would have frankly been been laying down
on their job had they not been working
really hard to deal with Wall Street
regulation because it was this
gargantuan share of our economy it may
be too early to start talking about
lessons learned but I often wonder if we
have changed permanently as a nation at
least for the foreseeable future when
you talk to people who lived through the
Great Depression they have some very
interesting precepts around savings
around hard work around the role of
government that really stamped them as a
product of their time what do you think
we're going to take away as a nation
from this current experience you know
it's it's really actually quite an
interesting question I mean I just never
mind the sort of big broad picture stuff
I just think about myself and and my
colleagues and friends and you know I
entered the workforce in the mid 90s and
and I remember just jobs were everywhere
and I just I felt like I could do
anything I wanted to I didn't have to
worry about any kind of security long
term or short because within a month
somebody's gonna call me and offer me a
job and everybody I know had that
experience and that shaped our our
understanding of of the world and and
how we moved through it
and I and I do wonder what the long-term
effect is of having had that pulled out
from underneath us and and people coming
out of school now who face a world
without jobs I
I don't know but I wonder if it will in
fact have a long time
cultural impact my fear is is is that
one of the ways in which this crisis and
this this this year of of raised hopes
and dashed hopes you know what one of
the things that it could leave us with
is cynicism like terrible cynicism about
about the possibility of political
change and that's what I find most
frightening when you think about this
whole generation of young people that
were so energized with the last election
and because as Kai said you know we have
such a consumer we don't really study
how movements actually are built we
don't really understand how social
change actually happens we still have
this very consumer idea about political
change you know I I paid for change you
know or I went to a protest and the war
didn't end why not you know and and and
so my worry is that people are just
going to be like yeah I kind of want my
money back and and not that it turns
into right-wing rage because I think
that's a different source but that it
just it turns into that's the last time
I'm going to deal with these jerks you
know so so that's my fear I my hope is
that there's going to be a kind of a
back-to-basics where movements are going
to be built once again on the issues and
based on principle as opposed to
everything being about elections and
party politics i mean i think this is
something i'm canadian and i think it's
one of the things that americans lose
sight of because you're in the middle of
it is just how odd it is to be
constantly in election mode you know you
were saying well what about 2010 i'm not
sure we should be talking about 2010 yet
i mean i think maybe we should be
talking about copenhagen and the fact
that we have the most important climate
summit coming up in two months and if
the obama administration isn't making
good on the hopes that they raised
living up to the hopes that they raised
about a real change on climate policy
then we need an energized environmental
movement and with with very clear
principle demands and and and and to
stop thinking like pollsters for a while
and strategists for a while because i
think the Bush years have left us with
this and our desperation to get the
Republicans out of office has co-opted a
huge amount of you know independent
media independent
ments where we all just think about
elections now which isn't actually
normal you know most parts of the world
you have you know anti-war movements
that are worried about ending wars less
worried elections I'm an environmental
movements that are really focused on
environmental policy so I'm hoping that
that will change and I one of the things
I see in it talking to college-age
activists these days is one of the
lessons that they took away from the
collapse on Wall Street is if you really
care about something do not leave it to
financial speculators that's important
because that that is the way once knew
that the way we have been told we should
deal with the climate crisis right
carbon trading cap-and-trade
market-based solutions so this is Larry
Summers is idea about how to deal with
climate and now I think we've got a
generation of young people who are going
no way and are coming up with more sort
of basic slogans about fossil fuels like
leave it in the ground
don't trade it don't build a derivatives
industry around it and that to me is is
a very very good sign I think well
that's kind of because this rise of
market fundamentalism if you want to
call it that over the past thirty years
Naomi I've been reading the shock doctor
in the last couple days and it's told as
a as a power-play and that's definitely
part of the story but it was also and
this is my little segue into getting to
my book for half a second it's it's also
this story that there were these
beautiful theories and it was sort of
this scientific movement and there were
people in it who didn't see themselves
as conservative warriors at all they
just thought they were doing beautiful
things with math to show how financial
markets work and one of the really
interesting things over the next few
years is what where economics and where
financial economics goes because those
theories didn't work so well and and I'm
not entirely clear where things go next
and and and there's been a lot of sort
of false starts because Naomi's good
friend Larry Summers he he was actually
in the early 80s one of the big critic
of all these elegant theories of perfect
financial markets and then he's just
sort of what as he's gone into public
life decided well you know
ever and and so that I don't have an
answer there but one would hope that an
event like this would cause lots of
younger people studying for their PhDs
and economics to start figuring new ways
to look at the world and then you'd have
new theories handy for whoever's trying
to push things in different directions I
mean it said further your the point of
your book I mean one of the important
points about these theories correct is
also that people got rich on them right
the people who had the theories the
academics got rich on them including
Larry Summers including Larry Summers
and and and that's part of how these
ideas become these neat ideas that don't
work in society have the staying power
because because they make people money
yeah and that is actually my one concern
about this idea of the rivetting
reinventing of economics Robert
Skidelsky the biographer of Keynes has
been pushing this idea lately that if
you want a PhD in macroeconomics you've
got to be studying English and politics
and history and all these other things
too but the problem from the perspective
of the economics academic economics and
academic finance is they get economics
professors get paid a lot more than
history professors or sociology
professors or English professors and and
so it's really in their interest to keep
it as this narrow yeah hard to
understand discipline but I mean it's a
crucial point that that Justin's making
because they're they're two really
distinct and interrelated components to
the revolution in economics one was the
theory revolution about let's say fair
the revival of laissez-faire economics
that opposed to Keynesianism
but the other was this war between the
numbers people and the people the
numbers people derive derided as the
essay writers who were the the Keynesian
economists and it was this this truck
that triumph of the complex mathematical
models and one of the things that I
think we need to take from this crisis
learn from this crisis is how dangerous
to democracy it is when all but the
tiniest sector of society feels that
that the most crucial question of any
society which is how do we allocate our
resources is too complicated for them to
weigh in on because it is all based on
these complex mathematical models that
are dreamed up in the basement of the
University of Chicago Economics
Department I mean that's that's another
thing that it's not just profitable for
them it's also fantastic for their power
because MIT part of the message is lay
people don't have a right to have an
opinion on economics so the other piece
of the puzzle and all this was a kind of
a silent coup d'etat within governments
where you take out more and more you
carve out more and more of what we used
to think of as governing of it and say
this is shouldn't be left in the hands
of elected politicians because it's too
complicated it has to be left to the
economists so in country after country
you have central banks that were that
were taken out of the reach of elected
governments and turned independent and
given to people independent thinkers
like Alan Greenspan for instance right
who of course have no ideology they're
just numbers guys often saying things
that are the opposite of common sense
right it's the driving of common sense
out of the public debate through through
through through creating a leads to talk
about it well in the in the spirit of
bringing the people into the
conversation those of you who have
questions signal by hand and we'll get a
microphone to you because it's being
recorded we want to make sure you speak
into the mic yes ma'am
I've been reading a book by an Italian
Roberto Saviano Kimura in which he talks
about the amount of money that the
criminal syndicates have at their
disposal to move from criminal
activities into business into ownership
into entrepreneurship all the way around
the world and I'm just wondering why it
is that you and the panel assumed that a
lot of the activities going on in the
financial sector are legitimate and not
criminal
I don't assume that I mean define
criminal and and first but I don't well
I don't know I mean I - I've got to say
I think there's you can create more than
enough mischief in financial markets
without criminal syndicates involved
they may be there I don't know yeah I
don't know but I certainly wouldn't say
that I would assume that what was going
on wasn't criminal I think it was I mean
now it didn't violate the law but that's
because they lobbied to get the laws
changed so they wouldn't violate them
i-i-i-i can't speak to the to the book
you ran or what what illicit center gets
exist but I I think it's important that
we do think about what was going on Wall
Street to be a crime I should mention
that some straight-up criminal right
money it just in terms of and I've spent
a little bit of time in Latin America
and looking at economies there and and
if there is everybody's sort of much
more open about yeah like this is drug
money and and then it was cleaned up and
put into the regular economy which
happened on a massive scale in Colombia
over the past two years where you know
the Colombian economy has done better
than other economies in Latin America
precisely because we're even allowed
just billions of dollars of narco money
to be brought into the Colombian Stock
Exchange this is absolutely out and they
open people know it and that money then
becomes another bubble for people to
speculate on another example of this is
the incredible role of the Russian
oligarchs in the global economy this is
dirty money we all understand that it
was made corruptly and now those same
oligarchs are going around buying a
flagship newspapers around the world to
just cite one of their major influences
so you know that money gets cleaned up
it but I think that this is a very old
story yet and that's the only that
that's the only thing I would add is
that a lot of I mean my country Canada
you know are some our richest family or
the Bronfman's they made their money in
the Prohibition
and we bootlegging so it's kind of an
old story sir this is for mr. Klein
I'm also Canadian so it's a little
off-topic but I just want to talk about
the Toronto Film Festival I just thought
that you're leading the protest against
it was amazingly courageous it's just
there's a film festival in Toronto right
now and she's leading the boycott
against because of the Tel Aviv
inclusion what's that it's not actually
a boycott it's a protest I'm sorry I'm
so sorry I just it's so courageous
because you like dove into the whole
issue even though that you knew that
this article that you wrote years ago
about that you're a self-hating Jew and
that you believe that Israeli men
masturbate to Holocaust pornography
remember that you actually did write we
have it's on the Internet and if you're
gonna change the topic at this point I'm
sorry I'm sorry miss Klein the question
was how do you have the big balls to do
that it makes me take the microphone
away from him any serious questions here
yes I think we've got one in the back
there yes hi I'm the IPF epi a financial
crisis is far from over
I'd like you guys to adjust the idea
that the toxic assets and complex
derivatives that I don't know no they're
still on the financial on the books of
the financial institutions right I don't
know who's unwinding them and I'm
wondering how big the obligations are
that are associated with them
yeah again I don't have any I can't
remember numbers like that I mean my
sense is those are the kind of things
that with the passage of time they work
themselves out but they remain this big
risk factor there and until they're all
gone and they're not it seems like in
the US financial system though the
really a lot of those assets the value
of them has been marked down enough on
the books that mariska x' it's there but
it seems like the bigger risk is just
lots of banks made lots of loans on
commercial real estate that are never
going to get paid back and and that's
the big thing going forward more
a lot of these well it's gonna be I mean
it the the banks that are in the most
trouble and that are sort of the
mid-sized to smaller banks and yeah
there's going to be lots of bank
failures oh it's gonna be a different
kind of bailout it's not going to be a
big tarp thing it's gonna be through the
FDIC and and to a certain extent you
know this is banks have done this since
the beginning of time they get in these
messes and there's this sometimes the
best thing to do is to shut them down
and start over sometimes it works out
fine to let them work through these bad
loans and survive and right now we're
going for door number two and hoping it
works I think we can get in one more I
still sort of believe in the good
intentions of the Obama administration
and maybe it's partially self-delusion
and maybe it's partially the you know
best for my mental health to believe
this but I guess what I wonder is what
does the administration really think the
underlying value is in what the
financial industry is doing what if base
is it adding to society and do they
think that this is not only desirable
but sustainable as a system of wealth
creation I don't actually know if it
does something productive for society
but I'm just wondering what you guys
think well I think financial systems are
it essential to the kind of economy we
run and and in in the right place they
they they are helpful they're not
productive in and of themselves they
just what they're supposed to be there
for is as intermediaries helping make
other economic activity happen and I
think the problem in especially the US
and the UK over the past really more
it's more than past ten years
like the past 30 years is they've grown
into these entities just that have this
whole logic of their own and I would I
can't speak for the people in the Obama
and mister
and I think the struggle they have is
they feel like okay this has value we
don't want it all to shut down at once
and clearly you know there are all these
regulatory suggestions they've come up
with which would have the impact of
shrinking the financial system some but
they're not willing to go for anything
more radical I don't know that I would
be either but others here might I mean I
think that that it a huge amount of
their response was driven by by fear and
and just not wanting to be the ones that
oversaw a deeper market crash and even
the appointments the appointment of
somebody like summers and Geithner these
were messages of reassurance to the
market of don't worry there isn't going
to be a radical change and that
stabilizes it's it's kind of short-term
thinking but I think that it is it comes
back to a Justin was talking about
before you know if they hadn't have
acted it could have been apocalyptic so
I think that that was probably it may a
major motivator but but I think rather
than speculating on good intentions or
bad intentions I think if you do believe
in Obama and want him to live up to the
hopes that he raised which I think so
many of us do then then he doesn't need
your faith he needs your pressure and
and he has said that really really
clearly and so it's it's it isn't in any
way a gift to him to just say you know I
believe in you I believe in your good
intentions it comes back to that great
FDR anecdote may be apocryphal that the
Eleanor Roosevelt used to say about when
when civil rights leaders or labor
leaders or somebody with some
progressive demand would meet with with
FDR and talk about what they wanted he
would list hear them out and say I think
that sounds like a great idea now get
out there and make me do it and and this
is where it comes back to the need for
independent movements that are not just
arms of political parties but are very
very clear and principled based and make
make his life easier because these are
the dynamics that brought the New Deal
in this country there was so much
pressure from the grassroots for radical
change that the New Deal was was able
that FDR was able to sell the New Deal
to the elites because the alternative
looked like revolution and those are the
only dynamics that have ever brought
real social change to not just this
country but any country progressive
social change and we need to remember
how to build independent movements again
we've lost the knack that is going to be
the last word all Naomi Klein author of
the Shock Doctrine Justin Fox author of
the myth of the rational market guy
right author of drifting toward love
black brown gay and coming of age on the
streets of New York I hope you all
enjoyed the panel the authors will be
around to sign their books and for
further conversation thank you so much